hello and welcome to this video who is
iTunes App each one [ __ ] up yep okay
c5 is a fairly normal still okay mm okay
invest some time in the opening why not
before it's also okay but should be 7s a
bit more interesting trying to trade the
beep all for the D porn okay spending
lots of time here I mean not time on the
clock but investing time for non
development
hmm I wonder maybe just knight c6 here
on 93
also just take the 60 simpler a simple
approach okay yeah then I'm keeping my
Center Forsythe or Bishop t6
hmm
yeah i'm just a pawn up before not much
I don't see how he's getting it back ok
can try Bishop g5 lose even more time or
B should be too f3m some some something
artificial
[Music]
just take me to him Bishop f3 I can
probably just take that pawn ok so like
to go D for now next couple of moves
yeah just cancel how do you refute that
96 is also probably good
okay I probably have to take and now
yeah everything's okay probably but
castles let's castle right 2h 30 that's
a strange game I don't I don't expect a
single move that my opponent is playing
and all a single one so just take it
okay who needs a pawn structure just D
595 looks fairly standard I just wonder
if I can do something better him
yeah do five c3 you're still a bit
slightly awkward we just prepare it
yeah probably just prepare it
a truck might come over to g form for
some Hail Mary a check and it's not
shouldn't be totally shouldn't be
underestimated okay I so check that I
drew gets no squares right if I go d 5
is going to ESS to sacrifice it right
test 0 squares
I maybe Quincy too
[Music]
so taking f7 here
but I don't think Italy that should lead
ii to all that much Knight takes I can
probably really just take c7 and here
the screen be one check check
so um what is the deal I take this and
all of chicks don't really want to
blunder into some some silly Jade so
double checking
No
check white resides I was a totally
weird game I didn't expect a single move
forever I be five is interesting it's
definitely playable here before Abu
should be 7f both are both interesting
and here the most interesting moves
probably 4s engine gives this is all
pretty much virgin territory yeah dd6 I
think it's just bad did before it's also
interesting I'm just limiting him no I
don't really see any compensation from
for whitey me4 is interesting yeah okay
Queen B 6 is given by the comp evil I
know that that move I didn't think about
interesting i probably five or no 95 and
if i grab then might be five again
interesting okay so that does make some
sense and here why this is struggling a
d4 was already possible that this was
also not bad but he takes him 94 is good
nite nite h 3 oz well that was strange I
mean black is always a bit better but
Queen d5 hear him
so but i think really black it's not
better I'm a porn up and he's got
terrible structure night on age three
mmm yeah okay but if you look at the
engine that it gives gives a regrouping
and maybe that doesn't work him and then
and then I had to do it differently here
somehow i 95 I didn't even think about
that movie that looks looks very logical
yeah I looking at all this and bring the
night over sorry to or to f6 ok yeah ok
guys thanks for watching